[Music]
on this sunday night
kofit 19 breaches the olympic bubble
with five days to go organizers defend
their pandemic game plan
the mingling and crossing of population
is incredibly limited
as the first athletes test positive
inside tokyo's olympic village
the uk's reopening gamble england
prepares to lift restrictions despite
surging cases and warnings from public
health experts
it's a complete mistake it's actually
outrageous
plus the devastating damage in europe as
flood waters begin to recede
and taking on the world's toughest
rowing race if there was going to be
a pinnacle challenge this is going to be
it meet the vancouver-based rower
gearing up to battle the atlantic
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with new trouble for
tokyo's olympic organizers with just
five days to go until the opening
ceremony
today confirmation of infections
involving athletes
inside the olympic village two south
african soccer players have tested
positive for covet 19. as mike armstrong
reports
in tonight's top story that's fueling
fears about the spread of the virus
when the games get underway
the olympic torch relay is the latest
sign these games
are going to be different the olympic
flames spent weeks
winding through japan but covid concerns
have now reduced it to a stationary
event
the flame passed by torch bearers on a
stage with participants trying to make
the most of it
those same concerns also meant the
official welcome banquet thrown by the
japanese government
was considerably smaller than usual this
is the international olympic committee
president arriving
sunday one of only 40 guests
outside the gates protesters calling for
the games to be
canceled the japanese capital is in a
fourth coronavirus wave
with a seven-day average of more than a
thousand new cases a day
this woman says it's unethical to hold
such a festive event
when the world is suffering so much
there is now a steady stream of athletes
into the country
about 11 000 competitors will be in
japan for the games
this is a video posted to social media
by a member of canada's field hockey
team
the majority of the athletes will be
staying in the olympic village they'll
be quarantined
for three days when they arrive and then
be tested daily
this is probably the most controlled
population at this point in time
anywhere in the world
for the first time two athletes in the
olympic village have tested
positive two south african soccer
players as well as a team official and a
rugby coach
all told the ioc says they've had more
than 50 cases
but that the measures and restrictions
in place should prevent
a wider outbreak the mingling and
crossing of population
is incredibly limited incredibly limited
these games won't be the party anyone's
used to
everything from hugs and handshakes and
high fives are banned
athletes are being told to stay inside
and eat alone
as often as possible and when their
events are done
they'll have 48 hours to leave the
country
mike armstrong global news british prime
minister boris johnson is self-isolating
after his health secretary tested
positive for coven 19.
the timing couldn't be worse tomorrow is
dubbed freedom day in england the
government is set to drop mask
requirements and eliminate social
distancing rules
as global shawn o'shea reports
scientists are worried that the return
to normal
will come at a high price
they call it freedom day great britain's
great experiment
no more social distancing and mask
requirements even nightclubs can fully
reopen if we don't
do it now we've got to ask ourselves
when will we ever do it
the move is being sharply criticized by
public health experts
in britain and in canada it's a complete
mistake you know what they're doing
there
is so absolutely not informed by
science and by data it's actually
outrageous
some british doctors are worried because
case numbers are rapidly climbing
there were more than 50 000 on saturday
the highest daily number in six months
it'll almost certainly get to 100 000
cases a day
the real question is do we get to double
that or even higher
and that's where the crystal ball starts
to fail
i just wanted to update you all that
i've tested positive for covid
the british health secretary is now in
quarantine and so is his boss
prime minister boris johnson a day
before rules are rolled back
i've been pinged i've been asked to
self-isolate
the chancellor and the prime minister
have been contacted overnight
by nhs track and trace which shows that
the system is doing its job
but that health care system may face a
new test one even larger than before
they will have reached the same ic
occupancy as they had during the last
wave by
mid-september dr peter uni says the
lessons for canada are clear
we should not gamble with this good spot
that we're in right now
in ontario which just allowed gyms and
movie theaters to reopen and
indoor dining to resume mass mandates
are staying in place for the moment
even though other provinces like alberta
have dropped those requirements
two-thirds of britons have received two
doses of vaccine
whether in england or canada dr uni says
the focus has to remain on vaccinations
then unvaccinated people that drive the
pandemic again
and hold everybody else back but also
put people at risk who are already
vaccinated please please please
the prime minister is urging british
people to get their shots and he says
to be cautious as the country leaves
covenanting safety
up to individuals sean o'shea global
news
in the u.s the delta variant is driving
up new cases
in all 50 states and america's
vaccination rates are stagnating
putting the u.s behind canada according
to oxford university's
our world and data 49 of canadians have
received both doses of a coven-19
vaccine
in the u.s it's 48 when it comes to the
first dose
it's 70 overall in canada compared to 55
in the u.s as jennifer johnson explains
the concern isn't just the number of
people becoming infected
it's also the severity of the illness
masks are back on in los angeles county
mandated after a new surge of covet 19
cases
until things really get back to normal
got to do what we got to do to get
things back to normal you know what i
mean new cases of coba 19 have doubled
in the u.s
in the last two weeks rising in almost
every state as the delta variant spreads
officials in la are taking no chances
it's not punishment
it's prevention we still have 4 million
people out of 10 million that haven't
been vaccinated
and many of them are young people
hospitalizations for copa 19 are also
increasing in several states
up more than 70 in florida and 150
in springfield missouri which is now
running out of hospital beds
we know what the solution is it's
vaccination people need to get it
it's readily available in nevada nearly
100 percent of the people in this
hospital's intensive care unit are
unvaccinated
with some of these variants it's passing
much more efficiently
and people are getting much sicker than
last year health experts expect more
mass mandates will be put in place
as hospitals become overwhelmed again in
areas where there are low numbers of
vaccinated people
or where cases are rising it's very
reasonable for
counties to take more mitigation
measures like the mask
rules that you see coming out in l.a
warning this fourth surge is just the
beginning
the centers for disease control is
urging everyone to get vaccinated
president joe biden is even taking on
facebook accusing the social media giant
of spreading vaccine
misinformation they're killing people
facebook is firing back
saying millions have used their vaccine
finder to get a shot
the battle comes as federal health
officials struggle to put an
end to this pandemic jennifer johnson
global news
washington to british columbia where
firefighters are working around the
clock to contain more than 300 fires
burning in the province
there are at least 37 fires of note
which could pose a threat to the public
crews are stretched thin and more
support will arrive from out of province
later this week
in some places residents are taking the
fire fight into their own hands a global
news camera was on the scene when one
rancher fought off the flames
the fire risk is high or extreme
throughout much of the southern half of
the province
and much of the continent is feeling the
effects of these fires
from bc to the prairies to ontario and
add in the western u.s
the smoke and haze can be seen from the
pacific coast
to the atlantic coast and even into the
far north
we have an update tonight on the turmoil
within the federal green party
global news has learned the party has
canceled a vote of non-confidence
in anime paul's leadership that vote was
expected to take place this week
it could have triggered a formal process
to remove paul
as leader coming up one year and still
no answers the tour of alberta that
ended in tragedy
it's been one year since a tour of an
alberta glacier turned tragic
three people died when their sightseeing
bus lost control and crashed at the
columbia ice fields
in jasper national park 14 others
suffered life-threatening injuries
and some of them are still recovering as
global sarah comedina reports they still
don't have answers
as to how this happened last year
devin earnest was on the final day of a
mountain vacation with his girlfriend
dionda roche
he couldn't imagine that he would be
leaving jasper national park without her
just feels like i lost myself lost
everything
deroche died when a big wheeled ice
explorer rolled down a rocky embankment
at the columbia ice field
landing on its roof i'm in a bad shape
right now
just still mourning over my girlfriend
i've just been suffering a lot from
anxiety depression 27 people were on the
pursuit tour bus
14 were injured and three people died
it's just scary to
it's scary for me i just really hope
nothing like that happens again rcmp
continue to investigate but don't expect
to release any information until fall
pursuit restarted the expeditions in the
spring and say they have added a number
of safety measures including seat belts
but having the buses back on tours
doesn't sit right for some victims
the investigation is still not completed
we don't know what was
exactly wrong renee patel was on the bus
with his wife
and 10 other relatives and friends the
two other victims who died can leash by
patel and grieva patel were part of his
group
i just walk around shouting for my wife
and
like looking people who are like
bleeding and not in a position to be
seen even not even positioned to get
recognized
so it was very very tragic
moment to forget there are multiple
lawsuits pending against pursuit
basil banzal is representing seven
victims
in the statement of claimant says the
company was reckless
the allegations against pursuit have not
been tested in court
and the company has not yet filed a
statement of defense
we don't want this to happen again it's
unfortunate that it happened to our
clients
and they should get compensation because
they've suffered a loss
but we want to make sure it's being done
right going forward patel and his wife
continue to recover from their injuries
but it's not as painful as the enduring
grief
we lost our loved ones and we need
justice
sarah comedina global news
still ahead why deforestation has turned
the amazon
against us in the fight against climate
change
you're watching global national
flood waters are still flowing through
parts of europe heavy rains caused more
flash floods in germany yesterday
this time in the southwestern part of
the country and just over the border in
austria
a torrent of water ripped through a town
on the outskirts of salzburg
more than 180 people died in the floods
last week mainly in germany
chancellor angela merkel toured the
devastation today
she called it surreal and terrifying
in india frantic rescue efforts are
underway after heavy rains triggered
landslides near mumbai
at least 30 people are dead but it's
feared many more may be trapped under
debris
the region has been inundated by monsoon
rains over the last 24 hours
several roads are flooded and train
services were disrupted
there's new alarm over deforestation in
the world's largest tropical rainforest
new research suggests parts of the
amazon are now giving off
more carbon dioxide than they remove
from the environment
and as crystal commansing explains
experts say the findings are a nightmare
scenario
in our planet's fight against climate
change
a logging site is not the image that
comes to mind for most when thinking of
the amazon
it is however an increasingly calm in
sight
and no trees means no ability to suck
carbon dioxide
from the air with climate change we
often seem to be
sleepwalking to disaster we keep getting
these wake-up calls but we're not waking
up
john schmoll is a professor in the
department of biology at queen's
university
he's deeply disturbed by the latest
research published in the journal
nature a team at brazil's national
institute for space research captured
nearly
600 air samples using small planes over
a nine year period
the lead author says the amazon as a
whole is admitting
three times more carbon dioxide than
it's absorbing
the eastern section where there has been
more deforestation
is admitting 10 times more co2 everybody
starts
to realize that we are
making a very bad work in preserving
amazon
you know and and that this is a very
urgency
a very urgent task for everybody take
care
the amazon is home to the largest
tropical rainforest on the planet
the climate within it is warming and
that says carrie bowman who has
several research projects based in the
amazon will have a knock-on effect
around the world the amazon is
absolutely
under siege and it's under siege on many
fronts
particular drivers is the relentless
push towards soy and beef farming
there are a number of complex issues
leading to the region moving from a site
that captures carbon to one that
produces the greenhouse gas
including burning the rainforest to make
room for crops
and livestock on top of that there's a
lack of environmental protections from
some of the countries
within the amazon basin that means we
even have to cut our greenhouse gases
even more
and that is a daunting task because we
already have enough trouble
meeting any targets that we set for
ourselves right now
the amazon was one of the largest co2
capture
sites and experts suggest if changes
aren't made
soon it could become one of the biggest
emitters
in the near future krystal gamansen
global news
london up next four friends versus
5 000 kilometers a vancouver-based rower
prepares for her
greatest challenge
this year 30 teams will take part in
what's known as the atlantic
challenge daring rowers will brave six
weeks at sea
starting in the canary islands and
ending in the caribbean that's almost 5
000 kilometers
and a vancouver woman is about to take
on that challenge
with three lifelong friends here's jay
durant
it's a rowing race unlike anything else
in the world
and when jessica mullins tells her
friends the anguish she's about to
endure and the risks involved
she usually gets the same response are
you mad
i get that a lot are you are you crazy
mullins will be at sea for about a month
and a half starting in the canary
islands and finishing in antigua
on this eight by two and a half meter
boat appropriately named by her team
we've named our team in deep ship
because that's exactly how we feel
they'll be trying to sleep in two hour
shifts while battling conditions like
this
the waves up to 40 foot
wildlife and then there are the marlins
several boats ran into trouble during
the last race
the marlin sphere actually penetrated
the boat
all the way into the internal cabin it's
probably the one thing
yeah the one thing that makes me most
nervous
she's taking this ultimate journey with
three long time friends who will be
relying on each other for survival
hoping they can all come out smiling on
the other side although it's physical
primarily it's a mental challenge so we
need to really understand each other
and know how each other tick so that we
can resolve issues
when we're out at sea
the team is raising money for three
different charities jessica has picked
covenant house
which makes this harrowing crossing
worthwhile it's considered
the hardest row in the world and as
mullen says
the toughest thing she'll ever do in her
life i kite surf
i roll anything on the water so for me
if there was going to be a pinnacle
challenge
climbing everest wasn't going to be it
this is going to be it
this is my challenge and our challenge
for each of us
jay durant global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is a trio of great
grey owls
senior caroline alberta we'd love to see
your corner of this country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching jeff simple will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow i'm on
vacation
for three weeks i'll see you again in
august have a great night